ratspräsidentschaft in zeiten von corona
praxis und klimawandel
deutschland hat seit heute den vorsitz
der eu und braucht viele gute antworten
bittere bilanz am arbeitsmarkt die
korona pandemie hat hunderttausende den
job gekostet millionen menschen sind in
kurzarbeit und härtere strafen und mehr
prävention die bundesjustizministerin
sagt wie sie gegen sexualisierte gewalt
an kindern vorgehen will
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und ihnen allen dass
es ihr nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
mittwoch guten abend auch an katja
stresow die den sport im blick
deutschland hat seit heute die
ratspräsidentschaft der europäischen
union und damit eine menge arbeit vor
sich und großem erwartungsdruck
europa muss nicht nur eine krise
bewältigen sondern gleich mehrere
das land das die präsidentschaft hat
kann dabei themen steuern und gesetze in
der eu voranbringen
ganz vorne das hat die bundeskanzlerin
gesagt steht der kampf gegen die korona
pandemie dabei geht es vor allem darum
die wirtschaft in der eu wieder
aufzubauen
zweiter schwerpunkt die brecht
verhandlungen mit großbritannien
abschließen und dann gibt es noch
essentielle themen die jetzt eigentlich
nicht zur nebensache werden dürfen der
klimaschutz und die digitalisierung
viel zu tun also für die kanzlerin und
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen aus berlin berichtet willi fischer
kroatien gibt die präsidentschaft weiter
nun zählt durch corona noch mal mehr die
eigenen erwartungen sind groß die von
außen
wir sagen nein wir werden wahrscheinlich
nicht jedes problem in europa in den
nächsten sechs monaten lösen können aber
wir wollen die wichtigsten probleme
lösen die die grundlage dafür sind dass
sich europa wieder schnell aus dem
wirtschaftlichen tal in das wir geraten
sind wegen der korona pandemie
herausbewegt dazu soll europas schulden
machen so haben es angela merkel und die
manuela chrome verabredet dem
wiederaufbau plan der eu kommission
stehen 750 milliarden euro
500 milliarden euro als zuschüsse für
schwache mitgliedstaaten 250 milliarden
als kredite nur ein plan bislang für den
die deutschen noch viel werben müssen
allein europäische maßnahmen können die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit nicht erhalten
sondern wir brauchen natürlich in jedem
mitgliedsstaat auch eigene zusätzliche
anstrengung um die schwächen zu
überwinden so wie wir das er mit unserem
eigenen konjunkturprogramm auch als
bundesregierung oder als deutschland
machen und so müssen es alle anderen
auch zu hause machen eine weitere
herausforderung des jahres ende der brh
exit fortschritte in den verhandlungen
sind hier um es zurückhaltend zu
formulieren sehr übersichtlich ich werde
mich weiterhin für eine gute lösung
stark machen
aber wir müssen und sollten in der eu
und auch in deutschland für den fall
vorsorgen dass ein abkommen doch nicht
zustande kommt und es gibt weitere große
themen die große erwartungen hervorrufen
verhältnis zu china digitalisierung
klimaschutz
bisher ist die deutsche bundesregierung
nicht gerade als treiber aufgefallen der
gesamten umwelt und klima debatte auf
der europäischen ebene
ich hoffe sehr dass ich das jetzt ändern
wird auf deutschland auf angela merkel
ruhen viele hoffnungen die eu
ratspräsidentschaft ist eine chance und
nicht weniger auch einem würde lieber
live nach brüssel zu unserer europa
korrespondentin anna guten abend was
erwarten denn die einzelnen
mitgliedsstaaten sind sie sich da einig
die erwartungen an deutschland sind
gewaltig deutschland ist das land mit
der größten bevölkerung und der
stärksten volkswirtschaft und deshalb
erhoffen sich alle viel von deutschland
aber durchaus unterschiedliche dinge
die südeuropäer wünschen sich schnelle
corona hilfen die sie nicht zurückzahlen
müssen
die nordeuropäer würden lieber kredite
ausgeben die zudem an strengere form
auflagen geknüpft sein sollten und die
osteuropäer haben angst dass sie in
zukunft weniger aus dem eu haushalt
bekommen weil sie von der korona krise
nicht so stark gebeutelt wurden alle
erwartungen gehen aber auch noch über
die korona hilfen hinaus wir haben uns
mal in europa umgehört
[Musik]
ich wünsche mir dass sie eine schärfere
klimapolitik betreiben dass sie wirklich
den grünen deal für europa durchführen
und die nicht aufschieben
es muss etwas bei der flüchtlingsfrage
geschehen deutschland musste helfen
vielleicht nicht mit geld aber mit einer
politik die unseren interessen dient ich
habe angst vor populismus
das ist die größte fest die europa quält
stimmen aus ganz europa jetzt ist ja
aktuell die situation sehr verfahren an
wie will denn deutschland sicherstellen
dass am ende des halben jahres rats
präsidentschaft dann konkrete ergebnisse
herausgekommen sind
ja es gibt natürlich gar keine garantie
dass deutschland wirklich alle probleme
der europäischen union in den nächsten
sechs monaten lösen kann zumal einige
von ihnen nur durch einstimmigkeit also
der zustimmung aller 27 staats und
regierungschefs überhaupt erreicht
werden können ein risiko zum scheitern
ist durchaus gegeben
bei den corona hilfen dem hilfstopf und
dem eu-haushalt allerdings ist merkel
die bundeskanzlerin ja schon in
vorleistung getreten
indem sie sich eingelassen hat auch
schulden machen und den schulterschluss
mit makro also da wird eine einigung
schwierig aber sie scheint doch möglich
bei den themen briggs it und migration
die wirklich sehr verfahren sind daran
könnten sich auch die deutschen durchaus
die zähne ausbeißen live aus brüssel
anne gellinek herzlichen dank und
deutschland übernimmt ab heute noch
einen wichtigen vorsitz nämlich den im
uno sicherheitsrat einen monat lang
leitet deutschland das wichtigste
gremium der vereinten nationen in new
york
und gleich zu beginn eine überraschung
es gibt eine resolution die zu einem
weltweiten waffenstillstand in corona
zeiten aufruft gehen wir zu johannes
hano in new york johannes wie viele
konkrete hoffnung kann sich die welt
denn jetzt machen dass das auch etwas
bewirkt der hoffnung macht erstmal dass
der un sicherheitsrat nicht in der
vollständigen politischen versenkung
hier verschwindet denn die blockade
haltung chinas russlands und auch der
usa hat in den vergangenen jahren immer
wieder dazu geführt dass man praktisch
keinerlei gemeinsame antworten auf die
grossen drängenden probleme hier
gefunden hat deutschland und frankreich
haben daraufhin eine starke
internationale allianz gegründet die
gemeinsames regelbasiertes handeln dem
recht des stärkeren entgegensetzen will
und das scheint jetzt früchte getragen
zu haben denn auch diese resolution hier
stand kurz vorm scheitern aber
eigentlich schon gescheitert weil china
und die usa sich nicht darauf einigen
konnten die whu in dieser resolution zu
erwähnen aber deutschland frankreich und
andere haben massiv im hintergrund druck
gemacht haben fäden gezogen an
schließlich eine formulierung gefunden
die es beiden jetzt möglich macht china
und den usa
da gesichtswahrend wieder rauszukommen
das wird hier als großer erfolg gesehen
gleich zu beginn der deutschen
präsidentschaft sagt johannes hano zdf
new york dankeschön
und damit nach deutschland wo in der
korona krise immer noch viele menschen
ihren job verlieren
insgesamt waren es im juni zwei
millionen 853.000 arbeitslose gemeldet
das sind 40.000 mehr als noch im mai
schaut man sich aber die monate davor an
dann zeigt sich es geht längst nicht
mehr so rasant nach oben mit der
arbeitslosigkeit wie noch zu beginn der
krise
ein grund viele firmen nutzen die
möglichkeit der kurzarbeit peter aumeier
coruna sorgt weiter für turbulenzen auf
den arbeitsmarkt jüngster fall airbus
15.000 stellen sollen wegfallen
über 5000 allein in deutschland
kündigungen nicht ausgeschlossen
die sorge am standort hamburg ist gut
wir wollen unsere leute hier behalten
wir brauchen die alle aus unserer sicht
und es darf nicht sein dass die gehen
müssen
zwischen april und juni sind nach
berechnungen der bundesagentur für
arbeit 638 1000 menschen durch die
korona krise arbeitslos geworden das
werden wir nicht binnen monaten wieder
aufholen
aber wir gehen natürlich davon aus dass
wir 2021/22 zum alten
arbeitsmarktgeschehen zurückkommen er es
gibt aber auch branchen da gibt es noch
arbeit genug wie in der bauindustrie
alle der 70 baustellen von manfred krom
pichlers firma sind im zeitplan
im prinzip laufen die baustellen alle
ziemlich auf hochtouren
von den lieferanten haben wir wenig
probleme gehabt dass wir unser material
beton bekommen und es gibt das
instrument der kurzarbeit dass die
arbeitslosenquote in grenzen hält mit
rund 6 millionen bezieher weiter auf
einem rückstand
aber es ist eben nicht so dass das
arbeitsmarktgeschehen vollständig zum
erliegen gekommen ist das denkt man das
ist aber nicht so denn der verkehr
tourismus verkauf handel und sozialwesen
da hat es einstellungen gegeben wie
schnell kann sich die konjunktur erholen
anders als die wirtschaftsverbände sieht
das ifo institut in seiner
sommerprognose bereits einen aufstieg
posten coruna teil
wir hatten ja den shutdown im april und
das ganze löst sich jetzt nur sehr
langsam von diesem sehr niedrigen niveau
im zweiten quartal werden wir etwas
wieder wachsen im dritten quartal und im
vierten quartal es gibt also eine
gewisse erholung die führt aber nicht
zurück auf das niveau vor der krise
sondern verlangsamt sich dann der
arbeitsmarkt weiter unter druck in der
wirtschaft geht es schrittweise wieder
aufwärts gestern der paukenschlag
ausgerechnet die eliteeinheit der
bundeswehr das kommando spezialkräfte
soll völlig neu aufgestellt werden
denn das ksk steht wegen
rechtsextremistischer vorfälle in der
kritik und zwar erstens massiv und
zweitens seit langem
heute hat die
bundesverteidigungsministerium ihren
plan erläutert der folgendes vorsieht
übungen und internationale kooperationen
des ksk werden vorläufig eingestellt
die zweite kompanie wird komplett
aufgelöst warum erklärt annegret kramp
karrenbauer so gern in der zweiten
kompanie
das können wir glaube ich mit recht zu
sagen in der tat eine mauer des
schweigens und nach aussagen auch des
kommandeurs ist das eine mauer des
schweigens die sich aus einer von aus
einer seite aus loyalität speist und aus
der anderen seite an
das alles sagt die
verteidigungsministerin heute ist der
erste juli ab heute ende hat sich
einiges in deutschland gucken wir uns
das kurz im überblick an
zum einen steigen die renten im westen
um 3,45 prozent in den ostdeutschen
bundesländern um 4,2 prozent und dann
die mehrwertsteuer
sie sinkt für ein halbes jahr von 19 auf
16 prozent der ermäßigte satz von 7 5
prozent damit soll die konjunktur wieder
angekurbelt werden so der plan der
bundesregierung die debatte um die
mehrwertsteuersenkung und konkrete
beispiele dazu können sie sich anschauen
in unserer zdf heute ein besonders
verstörendes thema jetzt münster
bergisch gladbach die fälle häufen sich
in denen sexualisierte gewalt an kindern
bekannt wird auf bundesjustizministerin
christine lambrecht wuchs zuletzt der
druck täter härter zu bestrafen
jetzt legt sie details für eine reform
vor missbrauch soll nicht mehr nur ein
vergehen sein sondern ein verbrechen
dasselbe soll gelten für die verbreitung
und den besitz entsprechender bilder und
videos das bedeutet höhere
mindeststrafen ariane gödel berichtet
noch nie ist in deutschland gegen so
viele tatverdächtige wegen
kindesmissbrauchs ermittelt worden
allein 30.000 spuren sind es im fall
bergisch gladbach diese zahlen haben
auch die politik alarmiert das
strafrecht soll verschärft werden
heute hat bundesjustizministerin
lamprecht ihre form paket vorgestellt
das ist selbst in einzelfällen bei
schweren sexuellen missbrauch von
kindern geldstrafen verhängt wurden
damit muss schluss sein das ist auch
wichtig dass dieser verfolgungsdruck auf
diese widerlichen täter noch weiter
erhöht wird der kern der reform der
begriff missbrauch wird durch den
begriff sexualisierte gewalt ersetzt
sexualisierte gewalt ist ein verbrechen
kein vergehen deshalb höhere strafen
mir ist ganz wichtig dass durch diese
heraufstufung auch es erleichtert wird
solche täter in haft zu nehmen auch wenn
keine fluchtgefahr und wenn keine
verdunklungsgefahr besteht kinderpornos
zu besitzen zu verbreiten ebenfalls ein
verbrechen
einziges video auf dem handy soll
ausreichen das ist ein deutliches signal
vor allen dingen an die betroffenen zu
sagen hier wurde unrecht getan es ist
ein verbrechen das die angetan wurde und
es ist auch ein signal an die täter das
ist nicht eine bagatelle ist
die grünen begrüßen die pläne für mehr
prävention wie fortbildung von
familienrichtern mehr geld und personal
für jugendämter und ermittlungsbehörden
wenn wir jetzt nicht alle instrumente in
der breite schärfen dann werden wir
kinder nicht besser schützen können der
kampf gegen sexualisierte gewalt gegen
kinder wird jetzt auch auf juristischer
ebene mit schärferen waffen geführt und
dann gucken wir uns jetzt in der sendung
die korona lage in deutschland an da
geht die zahl der neuinfizierten weiter
zurück im durchschnitt der vergangenen
woche haben sich täglich 420 menschen
mit dem virus angesteckt gestern waren
es noch 470 serbien hatte den kampf
gegen das virus eigentlich schon für
gewonnen erklärt und in der tat bislang
schien serbien in der pandemie
glimpflich davon gekommen zu sein
aber jetzt ist sie da eine neue welle
die täglichen neuinfektionen steigen
wieder deutlich an
im juni haben sie sich mehr als
verzehnfacht und es werden zweifel laut
von geschönten gar vertuschten zahlen
ist die rede
ärzte und krankenpfleger schlagen alarm
britta hilpert als die serbische premier
ministerin in corona hotspot novi pazar
ans mikro tritt sind aufgebrachte bürger
kaum zu berufen sie rufen die namen
ihrer toten an kubik 19 gestorben wegen
missmanagement und korruption meinen sie
auch das medizinische personal kehrt
sich ab die zahlen seien geschönt die
lage schlechter als zugegeben die
premier ministerin spricht von fake news
corona sei eben ein fruchtbarer der
infektions anstieg begann kurz vor den
parlamentswahlen corona lockerungen
verhalfen der regierungspartei von
präsident lud zum sieg mitsamt super
sprayer trompeten wurde gefeiert
kurz darauf waren drei
regierungsmitglieder erkrankt
die sorglosigkeit die lockerungen der
regierung beförderten die infektionsrate
meinen ärzte in der region nur wie
passat regierungstreue ist aber
unfähiges management verschlimmere die
situation
überfüllte stationen es fehle an
material und personal denn das sei oft
selbst infiziert
das gesundheitssystem ist offenbar
überfordert meint auch der arzt wegen
der politischen und nicht wenige
medizinische entscheidung gab es
innerhalb kürzester zeit hier einen so
rasanten anstieg in serbien herrscht nun
wieder machten pflicht deutschland hält
die reisewarnung für das land erst
einmal aufrecht als ein hoffnungsträger
im kampf gegen korona gilt das
medikament rinde sie wir die
us-regierung hat sich davon jetzt große
geplanten produktionsmengen gesichert
die trump administration kauft fast
alles was die amerikanische hersteller
firma bis september produzieren kann
wirkstoff dosen für mehr als 500.000
behandlungen studien zufolge kann reden
die sie wir schwere ko witt verläufe
verkürzen
die bundesregierung sagt sie habe
frühzeitig genügend mengen gesichert in
hongkong gilt seit der nacht das neue
sogenannte sicherheitsgesetz und die
behörden haben das gleich umgesetzt mit
aller härte war nicht genehmigten
protesten nahm die polizei mehr als 300
menschen fest tausende waren auf die
straßen gegangen
anlass war der jahrestag der rückgabe
der früheren britischen kronkolonie an
china vor 23 jahren
das gesetz gibt der zentralregierung in
peking viele neue vollmachten in der
eigentlich autonomen
sonderverwaltungszone wladimir putin als
russischer präsident bis 2036 das
erlaubt die neue verfassung über die die
russen bis heute abgestimmt haben kurz
vor ende des referendums am abend
zeichnet sich eine deutliche mehrheit
von rund 70 prozent ab
die abstimmung lief eine woche lang die
verfassungsänderung ermöglicht putin
nicht nur die kandidatur für weitere
amtszeiten sondern gibt ihm auch mehr
macht vereinzelt protestierten
demonstranten gegen die abstimmung in
moskau wurden und mehrere menschen
abgeführt und jetzt noch ein
unglaublicher drogenfund 86 millionen
amphetamin pillen beschlagnahmte die
polizei in italien
laut ermittlern wurde noch nie so viel
amphetamin sichergestellt
die pillen seien in syrien produziert
worden und zwar von der terror miliz wie
es sie finanziere mit dem drogengeld
ihre terroristischen aktivitäten
insgesamt sind die beschlagnahmten
amphetamine etwa eine milliarde euro
wert damit haben den sport katja und
jobs ist es wohl soweit die anzeichen
verdichten sich dass luisa nach münchen
zum fc bayern wechselt das bestätigt
sogar sein aktueller noch coach bei
manchester city pep guardiola
angeblich steht morgen schon der
medizincheck in münchen an
der 21-malige nationalspieler steht nach
vier jahren in der englischen premier
league vor der rückkehr in die
bundesliga sehr guten gesprächen das
kann ich bestätigen mit dem management
von lisa nähe und selbstverständlich mit
mancity laut medienberichten zahlt der
fc bayern für den 24 jahre alten
linksfuß knapp 50 millionen euro ablöse
die verpflichtung von edeltechniker sané
für hasan salihamidzic mit dem heutigen
tag zum sportvorstand befördert wäre es
der königs transfer bereits den
medizincheck hinter sich und in münchen
angekommen ist tango kouassi der
innenverteidiger von paris st germain
ist franzose nummer sechs im münchner
kader ja und weiter in der bundesliga
morgen abend gibt es das hinspiel in der
relegation zwischen werder bremen und
dem fc heidenheim bremen kämpft dabei
gegen den ersten abstieg aus der ersten
liga seit 40 jahren das 6 1 gegen köln
am samstag hat den abstieg vorerst
verhindert es soll aber kein grund sein
sich gegen heidenheim in sicherheit zu
wiegen
für mich stehen wir noch mit dem rücken
zur wand und zwar so was von also
es sind zwei spiele die darüber
entscheiden ob er in der liga bleiben
und dieses gefühl habe ich immer noch
bei der mannschaft dass die alle wissen
wir stehen mit dem rücken zur wand
im herbst gab es im dfb pokal einen sieg
gegen die heidenheimer zweitligisten die
dennoch nicht auf die leichte schulter
genommen werden sollen
hier unterschätzt keiner was sondern
volle fokussierung wir wollen das jetzt
unbedingt unbedingt zu ende bringen aber
neuland ist es schon ein
relegationsspiel hatte trainer kufeld
noch nicht und die zusammenfassung des
spiels gibt's dann morgen abend 23 15
hier im zdf super gespannt
genauso wie auf die lottozahlen die habe
ich hier und sie lauten 2 32 36 38 39 44
superzahl 1 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 7
heftige gewitter sind noch in den
nächsten stunden unterwegs alle details
dazu gleich von osten terry und dann
empfehle ich ihnen das heute schon mit
dem kollegen claus kleber um 21.45 er
hat fragen an bundesaußenminister heiko
maas zur deutschen eu
ratspräsidentschaft
morgen sind wir wieder für sie da punkt
7 aber erst machen sie sich alle einen
angenehm mittwochabend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter jetzt am abend und
der ersten nachthälfte gibt es hier im
orange schraffierten bereich teils
heftige gewitter nicht jedes gewitter
muss zum unwetter anwachsen aber die
gefahr besteht und dann gibt es
platzregen hagel und sturmböen
ansonsten lockert es im nordwesten auf
an den küsten gibt es einige schauer
die temperaturen sinken auf 12 grad am
niederrhein und 19 grad im südwesten
morgen am vormittag gibt es teils
heftige gewitter schon mal im süden in
diesem streckenbereich wieder ansonsten
nach norden teils freundliche abschnitte
ganz im westen kommen neue wolken auf
mit regen zum nachmittag können diese
gewitter teils unwettercharakter
erreichen und größeren hagel produzieren
platz regen und sturmböen um 100
kilometer pro stunde sind gut möglich
nach norden hin gibt es auch schauer und
gewitter sind aber nicht so heftig im
osten ist es teilweise freundlich
temperaturen erreichen sechs und 20 grad
im osten
18 grad an der nordsee das ist die
temperaturspanne für morgen die nächsten
tage bleiben warm einige schauer sind
durchaus dabei aber sie werden nicht
mehr unwetterartig sein
ein schöner abend